Samuel Leeds runs one of the biggest
property training companies in the UK he
boasts a large social media following
with 171,000 followers on Instagram and
recently he went viral after filming
himself chainsawing a front door on one
of his properties joining me now is the
man himself to debate his video and
landlordism in general Samuel thank you
for appearing on turn left it's great to
be it's great to be here I think debate
is healthy and um you know it's
hopefully have a fun discussion uh yeah
we'll see uh we'll see um but let's get
into it so a couple of days ago uh you
went a bit viral because you filmed
yourself chainsawing a front door
because and and to quote you a guest
hadn't paid um yeah but your lawyers
advis you not to do it but you said it
was fun and you did it anyway so why did
you do
it well it's interesting because yeah
when I say my lawyers advise me not to
do it um I guess there's two things
going on firstly there's the the PR
stunt side of it it which my lawyers
advised me not to do um and then there's
the actual evicting a guest in in that
way so just for the record it was and I
have been out on national TV it was a
stunt I wasn't actually evicting a
tenant or a guest however I did it for a
few reasons the first reason I did it
was to um show the fact that the media
will just jump on stuff regardless of
trying to actually get the facts so I
just said oh there's a guest that hasn't
paid there's a big difference between a
guest and a tenant legally and all the
headlines were landlord of Vick's tenant
didn't ask me any questions didn't find
out well hang on maybe there's a a broel
going on yeah I mean I suppose that the
implication is quite strong there I mean
you are a famous landlord and you're
tearing down the door and saying
someone's not paying so I mean I agree
that the media is quite toxic sometimes
um but I don't think it was unreasonable
to think that I mean we we were all
thinking it and I and I'm pretty sure
that when you made that video you knew
that was the implication so I don't know
if you should get really annoyed if
becomes that conclusion because it was
it was it was implied right but that's
the point I would be annoyed if people
came to the conclusion no but the media
and Reporting it and saying this
happened without having the facts it's
just ex it's just it shows what the
media are like it shows that they'll
just run with stories Sensational
headlines um so what was what was what
do you think particular was wrong with
the reporting well for a start it wasn't
it I I never said that there was a
tenant in the
property um and and in in my my post I
made it very clear that it was a it was
a property used for guests it was it was
actually a hotel C1 class so the fact
that they said tenant um is you know was
was was not true had not come from me um
and also just the fact that they made me
out to be the bad guy demonized me to be
a terrible landlord when actually
without knowing the facts I mean as I
said it could have been that it was been
used for a brothel it could have been
used for a legal storage who knows what
the facts were and they didn't they
didn't care or ask they just thought oh
this will be a sexy headline you know so
that was and I think there's a lot of
landlord bashing that goes on I know
we're going to get on to talk about this
but like
landlord greedy horrible and I don't
think that's the case I think a lot of
landlords are struggling themselves
financially a lot of landlords are good
compassionate people but there's a lot
of um people that think just because you
own a property and you're a landlord you
know you're you're bad person I don't
think that's true at all okay well we
are going to come on to that but to go
back a second um
I think again like the implication here
is that it was a very it was a publicity
stunt I mean look you said it on GB news
that it was It was kind of fake I kind
of guess that but then that leads me to
think what was the point because you've
You' you've cost yourself your own money
by chainsaw and your door down to make a
point and this is and this is at the
time when we have a housing crisis we
have a cost of living crisis people are
struggling to pay rent and you've just
added more anxiety to and and you think
that um uh landlords are persecuted that
is one of the most delusional things
I've ever heard in my life is really
unhinged but again we'll get on to that
but tenants are facing a tough time and
you're just adding anxiety to that
you're adding fuel to the fire so again
I asked what was the real broader Point
here apart from just okay the media side
the media is bad great we we kind of
agree on that but what was the broader
Point well for a start it's got us
talking hasn't it yeah it's getting
people thinking and talking about these
issues which I think is a good thing so
as what the the intention behind it I
think is it it's exposed the media that
they just jump to sensationalized
stories and print without actually
factchecking and it's got people talking
about these important
issues but I'm assuming obviously you're
coming it from the angle on the pro
landlord side obviously and and they'll
be ridiculous to to claim otherwise you
are a
landlord well yeah but that doesn't
necessarily mean that I'm I'm I'm of
course I'm a landlord but at the same
time that doesn't mean that I'm going to
be completely biased and I'm going to be
fighting for landlord and at the expense
of of tenants um not at all um I I'm a
landlord and I have a lot of properties
but I also I'm grappling with things as
everybody is on a day by day about the
best way to be the the best way to
behave the best way to act um so yeah I
mean I'm but I'm also prum okay um again
I'm I mean I've obviously I've done a
bit of research on you and I've seen a
couple of things you've done before when
you say stuff like that and then you
Tweet stuff saying poor people are poor
because they're lazy and you can see if
they're poor within 5 minutes can you
see why people might have a picture of
you or there's videos actually what I
said that's actually not what I said
slightly misquoted okay I mean I have
the Tweet but what do you mean by then
I'll give you a chance to
clarify um what I actually said you you
were almost word for word you just
missed I think from me my memory you
missed out the word most most poor
people that is that is still pretty
antagonistic though if you say most poor
people I mean do you believe that do you
think that most okay not all but most
poor people are
lazy I think most people are lazy right
so are you
lazy um I'm lazy I can be lazy I've been
lazy when I've done jobs that I don't
particularly enjoy sure I've been very
lazy about the job yeah um yeah I think
and I said I can I can tell whether
somebody's wealthy or or poor within
five minutes of meeting them that how do
you know what's the what's they
identified to know that they're rich or
poor or whatever question um you can
tell by the way that they think and act
around money so if somebody's hate if
somebody hates rich people and thinks
that if you make a lot of money it's
unethical it's bad then the chances are
they're probably not going to be rich
themselves because if they were they'd
be you know if any if that if they come
across a business opportunity they're
not going to take take up on it and
become rich because they don't believe
the rich people are good people and
everybody wants to be a good person so
most people that believe that rich
people are greedy rich people are jerks
and they speak badly on rich people yeah
I mean sure but that is slightly
different to saying that they're lazy
because there are there are people there
millions of people who work incredibly
hard just like an for example and
they're poor and they're and they're
struggling and that is because I mean I
would argue as a socialist it's down to
the the economic system Rin to say that
most people to try and quote you
properly most people are lazy or sorry
most people are poor because they're
lazy that's just factually Incorrect and
I think again if you are trying to say
to the media that landlords have a bad
rap and then you're someone who's you
know you you're doing very well for
yourself You' got hundreds of portfolio
hundreds of properties in your portfolio
you're a multi-millionaire so then say
things like that it seems like you're
not helping yourself right yeah I think
you yeah I think you got a good point in
terms of definitely not all po I mean
I've been to some of the poorest parts
of the world and and I also believe that
some of the poorest people are the
hardest workers sure I've met I've met
people that are extremely hardworking
and they've not they've not got anything
so yeah I I agree with you it definitely
isn't the case for all people and that's
why I said most and we can debate
whether even that's correct it might not
be most I definitely think and my
audience that I'm speaking to you know
people that are trying to be Su in this
country the opportunities that we've got
to create wealth and to become
successful um are huge and for people my
audience and for people that are wanting
to be successful and wanting to start
businesses but they don't and they and
and and then they complain about it I
think that the generally the majority of
the case is that it's because they're
lazy so you don't think there's any
economic barriers to it you don't think
that the economic system is rigged
against them because this is the thing
like it look no one says and I would I
would say the majority of people in this
country don't hate rich people in fact I
think we have a bit of an obsession with
rich people that we seem to think that
they're they're Geniuses and there's
there's something special about them
like you're a billionaire because you
work really hard but you're ignoring all
of the other um faculties within the
economy that that can stop people from
being successful and one of them
obviously I think I think I've kind of
got you to agree that look hard work
doesn't just come uh I agree with that
right exactly you could be a hard worker
and not get somewhere and then it kind
of pivots to well it's it's about being
smarter um most people don't think that
people are successful or bad people or
anything like that but that if you're
from a poor background statistically
you're more likely to end up being poor
and if you're someone who's gone through
social Mobility has grown up from zero
to nothing I've seen your front pages or
not front page I've seen your stories
that you said you've gone from Rags to
Riches that can happen but it's it's the
exception not the rule so it doesn't
mean that you didn't work hard or other
people didn't work hard to get to where
they were but majority of times that's
not what happens and I guess again
seeing this sort of rhetoric angers a
lot of people so you might be thinking
that oh people are just um well yeah
sure but I think people you might be
thinking people are just jealous and
that's why they're angry but actually
they recognize there's there's a broken
economic system at play here yeah but if
it pites people if it pisses people off
and they're and they're annoyed then
that's good because then it it might it
might make people um you know know work
harder or or take personal
responsibility and there definitely is
an economic of course if you're born
into rich rich family it's going to be
way easier for you to be successful and
to be you know than if you're born into
into poverty or born into into nothing
absolutely but I think that personal
responsibility is a good thing and if
you take responsibility and say
regardless of my background regardless
of my finances of my parents and and
everything like that I believe that I
can be successful I'm going to take
personal responsibility I think that's a
good thing well I I would say that most
people do take personal responsibility
and I think there's I mean you said that
there's a bit of a persecution from
landlords in the media I would say the
opposite is true there's so much um uh
propaganda against people who are in low
paid work those on Universal Credit
they're just lazy they're just uh
stealing off the state when you got
actually most people uh on Universal
Credit are in work for example so I I I
think you might say sure that's a factor
but I would say that is like 99% of it
that doesn't mean you shouldn't work
hard
that doesn't mean you shouldn't take
personal responsibility but I think when
people see someone who's very successful
especially through Landers and we're
going to get into the meat this in a
second you get on to that and then
you're struggling and then you you got
Samuel Lee the big influencer making
publicity stunts I I I get why they're
angry but um it's not a bad thing though
it's not a bad thing because a lot of a
lot you know I can I can name hundreds
of people that have come from nothing
come from a poor background that I've
seen my post like that and it's made
them think damn Maybe right maybe I can
make something of my life maybe I can be
successful and it's and and it's pushed
people had a positive effect I mean I
remember when my my doctor about a year
ago I was in Uganda and I was five Stone
heavier than I am now so I wasn't taking
responsibility of my of my health and I
met a doctor in Uganda and he ripped me
for being fat and he was really hard on
me and it actually had a positive effect
on me now for some people that would be
say yeah not not everybody's response
the same do they and some people will
respond to my tweets and be angry and it
might not be helpful and then some
people might be inspired and everybody
you know but my my my intention is is
definitely to see people win and to help
people is not to try and T people might
look like I a bold claim you know the
the the landlord is the philanthropist
he's actually just trying to get egg
people on but look let's um let's get on
to the meat of landlordism right because
when you want on GB news I mean look I
think GB news is a right-wing media
channel um the the the presenter he he
barely pushed that back on anything you
said but he did talk about the fact that
look there are people in a far desperate
situation than you are um and he said to
you that can't you just let him off a
rent and I've got my personal opinion on
this as well but I want to ask you about
that yeah well I mean every Situation's
different and you you know if you've got
a tenant not paying rent of course
you're going to have to make a call and
decide what what everyone's going to
have to make a call and decide what the
right thing to do is but my point is
that you can't you can't go into sabur
and take food and just say look it's a
commodity it's a human right let me have
it for free they wouldn't allow that
sorry I'm just cut in but that that
analogy doesn't work because let's take
your example going to Saints Breeze and
you said it's it's a commodity that's a
commodity s Breeze is producing for you
and you're taking it away so s s at a
loss but you're you still got the deed
on the property the property is still
yours if someone's not paying rent it's
just factured incorrect it's annoying
but it's fact incorrect to say it's
stealing from you because the property
the quantity is still yours all right if
you try and uh borrow if you take a car
from a garage say it's necessity I need
to get to work I'll borrow it for
free you won't be allowed you'd be a
criminal yeah but again that's still
taking the commodity away from
someone so so what I mean by this is
landlords and I'm I'm going do this more
broadly landlords have power over the
tenant right you have control of the
propery and as you just said if tenants
don't pay you have the state that backs
you the state backs you to kick these
people out so there is no situation
where a landord is really at risk is
there but at the same time tenants are
in a in a far more precarious
situation I I disagree I think that I
mean for a start if you've got a
property most landlords have got
mortgage payments and stuff so if you
might be you might be paying £500 a
month on the mortgage then you've got
your insurance and all your running
costs sure but but I could say so what
so what to that because at the end of
the day if you're a landlord you've got
the tenant they're paying for your
mortgage right you're you're taking
money and profit off of the back of
someone else who's actually going to
work so if you've got a mortgage to pay
then you just got to join the world you
join the rest of us and go go go and get
a job and make an income to pay for that
mortgage the point is that if if a
tenant doesn't pay their rent what
happens to them is they're most likely
going to be evicted they're going to be
potentially homeless on a far more
precarious situation if you're a
landlord and a ten tenant doesn't pay
rent you're not in that same situation
either you're in your situation who does
very well for himself probably wouldn't
even notice or and and but or another
landlord who's got one little property
doesn't make much profit um but it just
means he has to do what the rest of us
do and just get a job and pay for a
mortgage the the point is why are
landlords entitled to someone else's
income
when really in society being a landlord
doesn't add any social utility it
doesn't provide to society and my
argument is that yeah not in a personal
attack but landlords are a leech on
society again this is not a personal
attack this is just a a descriptor of
the economic situation so for me sorry
go go go no no go on go on no I was just
gonna say it it just shocks me because
you seem like a very intelligent
articulate person very you know
articulate but what you're saying
doesn't make to me doesn't doesn't make
any sense how is I'm happy to explain it
again well yeah I mean just make any
sense at all and and and I'm I'm not
coming on here trying to be a big I am
and try and shoot somebody down or prove
you wrong I'm not not here to do that
I'm here because there's a lot of people
that think like you yeah and I don't get
it I mean how is it any different from
any business if you're selling um
anything or or offering something
whether that's for rent if you if you
have two B Les and you ride one and you
rent the other how is that different
from having two properties and you live
in one and you rent the other I mean I'm
happy to explain the the difference so
um okay I I'll give you an example you I
don't know if you follow um
americanamerican politics that much but
recently there was a writer strike of
The wga Writers Guild of America and
basically There Were Striking one for
increase in Pay but two for residual pay
and if you don't know what that means
that essentially is uh actors or
creative workers who've worked on a
project on a movie get paid their wage
but you then got streaming services who
are continue to stream continue to make
profit yet these people who actually put
their labor and put their creative
skills to work doesn't get paid for it
so you've got a streaming platform that
doesn't really add much Social utility
much value yet they get to to have the
The increased profits or the the future
profits where the laborers don't and
this is the sort of the where I see
landlordism at is that I think and most
people in Society think that you should
you should work and you should bring uh
social utility to society we don't like
freeloaders we don't like people sitting
on their ass and do nothing you know I'm
a lefty so I'm a big supporter of the
welfare state for example because I
think we need social safety there but
there are people who don't think that
yet we don't apply to the same to
landlords because you got to think what
is the social utility landlords are
actually bringing now if you're paying a
mortgage we would agree that's probably
probably the value of the house okay the
mortgage is the repayment back to the
lender landlords come in will pick up
the mortgage bill or buy it outright
then add a profit onto the rent to the
tenant and then the tenant doesn't even
own it so they're in a far worse
position they're paying more for less
and that doesn't seem to make any sense
whatsoever so that's why I say that
there's no social utility from from
landlords or landlordism because they're
not actually providing they're not doing
any laborous work or Pro actually
producing a product for society now you
brought up businesses again I I would
disagree the analogy here because a
business that whether it's a product or
something they are producing that
product someone is purchasing that
product and then they're keeping it they
now own it but when it comes to housing
especially renting people are paying
more than the than the market rate for
the mortgage yet they're not owning
anything and they still don't have full
control and the L can still kick him out
that doesn't seem very fair it seems
totally fair I mean I've been a tenant
and I've also had properties and had
tenants I've been on both end of the
spectrum and when you a landlord
your product is your property that's
your product that's your service and
your tenant is your customer it's just a
business if you you've got something
that people want yeah and then you're
charging the going right for them to
have it I mean I wouldn't say it's what
they want though it's what they need and
this is the problem the the biggest
up of human society I think is the
commodification of housing we don't do
this for anything else and actually even
food we don't do it for food because
once again as the analogy we brought
earlier purchasing food that is still
something that that I now own when I
bought it we we stopped it with
Healthcare right in the US you got to
get uh health insurance and we I
particularly think it's absolutely
screwed up that you can get corporations
profiting of people's illness now
thankfully in this country we built the
NHS because we realized we need to De
commodify Healthcare people need it it's
not a choice and that's the same with
housing fair enough if you're going to a
restaurant and you're getting a service
you're going on Netflix and purchasing
service or you're buying something these
aren't human rights but people need to
rent and when you realize that majority
of but we have that in the in the UK we
have we have Council houses and we have
benefits you know if if someone's
struggling they've not got a job job
Seekers allowance if you if you if you
you need to live somewhere and you
haven't got the money the council will
obviously is not going to be incredible
beautiful big fancy house but we do have
that in the UK I mean I would say we
used to have it with count I'm glad you
brought up ciz actually because we used
to believe that social housing was a
good thing and then Margaret Thatcher
came along brought in a new liberal
reforms and essentially create a world
of landlords and now we've we've sold
off a lot of our Council houses and as I
brought before we have a housing crisis
there is actually a shortage of Housing
and then we have some lands that are
buying up the stock inflating the prices
and then people who many people who
don't want to rent are forced into it
because they can't afford a house they
can't afford a deposit and they're stuck
in this Cy cycle of renting because the
and I was doing research on this the
average rent cost in the UK is more than
a mortgage so how would it be for a
first-time buyer who's working minimal
wage or or whatever and they're working
really hard and half their income goes
to rent and they're actually paying more
than they would be for a mortgage so
it's like it's kind of a catch 22 and
then we have people who are exploiting
that situation just for profit it is it
seems incredibly um doesn't seem very
sustainable I think that you say
exploiting the situation for a profit
and I get that it's tough I mean the
average salary and then you look at the
average rent it's it's it's not easy to
just live live you know just live a
comfortable life it's not it's tough and
I and I get that fully but I don't see
really how what I'm doing buying
properties renting them out is
exploiting the situation I mean for a
start a lot of the nearly all of the
properties that I buy they're rundown
houses so if you're buying a rundown
house that's a property that's it can't
be bought by first time buyer it's not
going to be bought by even a buy to that
landlord so I'm buying houses do them up
and then renting them out now what I'm
actually doing by doing that is I'm
bringing more
houses into the country so it's it's
helping the hous in crisis I I I've I've
just built um we bought a factory where
we've got planning permission I'm in the
process of building 48 new houses at the
moment I
mean
that's okay so I I kind of disagree with
that because um I don't think landlords
provide housing and I think that the
idea that housing exists is because
landlords I think it's a fallacy what
you're doing in that situation is you're
providing Capital right but it's the
workers it's the laborers who are
building that house they're the ones
that's producing value for society now
why aren't the the Builders of the house
why aren't they taking 99% of the profit
why are you going to take 99% of the
profit because why wouldn't you I mean
that's your position you're I understand
what you're trying to do and this is the
point where I'm saying not saying that
all landlords are bastards that that's
far from it there are people who
probably think that but that's not my
analysis of the situation it's I'm not
making a moral argument here I'm making
a systemic argument so the laborers
those that build the house they're the
ones creating value for for society and
you're taking the value away from it by
pocketing the cash so I would dispute
that you're really building houses plus
there's multiple ways how you can bring
houses uh into society we touched on
Council housing and there are things
such as um what we should be doing is
renting from the state I think it's a
great idea because what you have essenti
is um one way you could do it is you
rent out at cost price so the person who
wants to be a tenant doesn't have to pay
extortion at pricing um another way is
um uh Mutual housing or cooperative
housing uh we used to have them actually
building societies Nationwide used to be
one of them Northern Rock before they
bought off by private Banks and you had
communities that come together and pull
the resources together to build a lot of
Housing and the people got the the worth
of the investment they weren't ripped
off anything so I I dispute that
landlords are bringing housing now I
will slightly agree that under this
current system you can't just um ban
landlords uh overnight there is a
transitional period here obviously but
the fundamentals is I disagree that lels
are providing service or anything of
social value of social utility
now a lot of landlords only have one
house don't make much of a profit and
this is why I do want to Pivot back to
you because your company is it Samuel
Le's property is that what you called
I've got quite a few s got s Le Holdings
which which is the company above all the
companies yeah um but then your old
company used to be buy low rent high and
this is the thing where I kind of talk
about exploitation again when I say
exploitation is not trying to make a
necessarily moral argument it's just a
systemic argument yeah when I mean there
there's a video of you that went again
quite viral I mean you're pretty good at
social media I'll give you that um and
you were talking about you need to buy
low and rent High the problem with that
is that I would say that's definitely
exploitation because that would you not
agree that's inflating house pricing
would you not agree that's inflating
rent and plus that's also form of
gentrification because if you go into an
area which has got low lowc cost housing
those in that area might not be able to
afford those rents because you've now
just hyped at the price I would say
things like that is exploitative so I
would say that landlords existing in
itself is exploitative whether you're a
good or bad person and then obviously
yeah I am pivot to you specifically I
feel like these things are kind of
exploitative as well H I mean I mean buy
low rent High what what what what that
is is it's when you buy a house and you
buy it as cheap as you can negotiate
well and then you rent it out split it
up rent it out room by room which again
ironically is actually making more
affordable I mean the reason that rents
are so high is because there's a
shortage of rental properties that's why
they're high so when I buy a property
and turn into a HMO and turn one prop
property into four or five units then
I'm actually Bringing Down the cost of
rent because I'm making I'm bringing
more Supply into the marketplace but
then aren't you also shrinking the size
of the house so so yeah but again that
that seems like you're just admitting
that's been a bit exploitive right I
mean I don't know if you seen there was
this this amazing picture on the
internet really good of somebody
purchased a house or they're renting and
in the room it was half a window I if
you seen it it was quite it was quite a
famous picture and there was a wall
built inside it now this room used to be
quite big and it was clearly a Lano came
in turn this room into one room which is
barely functional as a room and then say
Oh it's got more it's got more bedrooms
therefore it's higher in value things
like that I don't see that adds value
that
actually I would say even decreases
value inhumane that's the problem it's
inhumane you're renting your property
out when I'm renting out properties room
by room that first I'm abiding by the
law and there is laws and regulations to
govern how big the room could be has to
be at least 70 square feet it needs to
have natural daylight and and and so you
know if you break the rules and you're
unethical and you rent out little rabbit
run rooms then you're probably going to
end up with all kinds of problems and
legal problems as well but I think
providing providing uh accommodation
feed where they've got a nice little
room and on Suite bills are included 500
p a month that's it's it's really
helpful to people because at the minute
what people going to do rent and if
you're if you live in the middle of
England in Birmingham which is where I'm
from you can rent an apartment for say
£700 a month then you've got all your
Bells then you've got your furnish the
property you're talking a grand a month
just to have a roof over your head well
your salary is only two grand so you're
screwed whereas if I come along AG go
actually buy low rent High I bought a
cheap house here and I'm renting out
room by room you can rent a room off of
me for500 it's a nice room it's fully
furnished a super fast Wi-Fi you've got
an on suite500 pound a month bills
included that's offering that's offering
a service the fact that I'm profiting
from that first of all they're pay I
mean they're paying for the service
right because this is unfortunate thing
I don't know about you but there are
some landlords who obviously charge the
I mean they're paying for your mortgage
and then you're adding the markup to it
and then they don't even fulfill the
services right that's one issue that's
not good and and you might that's thing
you might say that's not good but that's
the system that allows it to be because
I want to touch on what you said before
you said well I'm following all the
rules all the legislation I'm staying
within the confines of um the legal
system that to me isn't necessary a case
to say well I'm doing fine then because
I think the the legal system that
supports T is weak um we we struggled to
get I mean r&p struggled to pass through
legislation to make sure that homes were
fit for human habitation and it just so
happens at 90 MPS are landlords um you
recently actually posted yourself quite
a while ago that the government has now
made it easier for you to turn a house
into small different Flats as we just
discussed and you're making more a
profit of it that doesn't seem like yeah
it's technically legal but it doesn't
seem like it's right but again rejoicing
you should be rejoicing that that new
law that's coming in permitted
development well then why would I
Rejoice though that when someone comes
in looks at the value of a house and
says right I'm now going to like charge
double or triple at the same time when
you agree that there people strong to
find places to rent when we have a
situation where people are bidding on
renting people paying all up front it
doesn't seem very fair why is the growth
of landlords the growth of landlords has
also meant that housing has become more
precarious because your log your logic
would mean that the growth in landlords
mean it'll be even better but the
housing crisis has only got worse and
yes it's down to building but it's B to
a multitude of things by not be able to
get on the housing ladder because
they're stuck in rent the reason that I
say you should be rejoicing is because
again being turning one house into two
means that you're providing more
accommodation and it means you've got
more of a supply of houses more of a
supply of houses means the houses become
more affordable and going back to my
development one of my development St at
the moment where I'm turning a rundown
deric Factory into 48 properties um
again that's that that is massively
contributing to homelessness it's
massively contributing to affordable
housing well homelessness is on the rise
though so how how can we square that
Circle and I'm genely interested like
please explain homeless is on the rise
yeah we've more people more people like
me and then homelessness will be sold
right so people are homeless because
they're not hardworking or not smart as
you that's why is that no that that
people are home no not at all I me that
might be one reason why some people are
homeless um another re people homeless
for many reasons one reason is because
lack of Education one reason is because
lack of compassion and people don't
realize that they exist one reason is
because of lack of um affordable
properties there there there's many
reason why homeless people addictions
drug addictions yeah I'm I'm doing more
for homeless people than just about
anybody that I know I'm going out and
not only financing Charities working in
drug rehab centers providing affordable
accommodation educating people to to to
be able to be smart with their money
yeah um and by that's good and I would
encourage anyone I mean first of all
when homelessness exists when Charities
exist that to me is a a symptom of an
ill Society we shouldn't have that um
and good being a philanthropist is great
if you go and do those things I think I
think encourage anyone to go do these
things but I would still say that like
that doesn't even though it's good that
still doesn't counter out the system
that we're living
in well you asked about you said about
the builders you know what why are they
not getting paid all the all the profit
well the reason they're not getting paid
all the profit is because
they're not putting in any risk I'm
putting in all the risk if the
development goes goes all go goes
problematic it will be me that will have
to put the bill well then but the risk
thing though that everyone there's a
shared risk there's a there's a risk for
tenants I mean people are it's incure
housing there's a risk for for workers I
mean the IDE there's zero risk is not
true but again with the situation
there's no risk there's no risk worst
case scenario well no not for the
builders for the for the laborers and
the builders that are actually putting
the bricks stand there mixing the cement
me saying to them hey I'll pay you yeah
I I'll I'll pay You2 200 a day to come
out and mix cement I mean gez what's the
risk for them that after a week I'll
stop I'll just stop paying them and then
they'll just go all right next and go to
the next job there's a risk whereas for
me I I bought this building for a
million pounds of my own hard earned
money got planning permission had to
work with the councils paid £410,000 to
the community of w Hampton and sure but
that that's that's providing Capital but
again I don't think I don't see how
that's risk and
but also in terms of sorry it's not
capit it's more than that it's also
coming up with all of the drawings
paying taking on all of the risk and
paying people and providing employment
for people which also helps homelessness
to come and putting together a team of
expert planning Consultants expert
Architects Builders quantity surveyors
giving all these people jobs to turn
this rundown deric Factory into 48
properties and the risk here I want to I
want to this point about risk because
please do if if if you if you have a bad
investment or something goes wrong the
worst situation is you'll end up like me
or like other people who have to pay
their mortgage that's one thing but
there's there's also I said everyone in
in this situation is in a risk I said
the tenants I mean we didn't really talk
about tenants they they have a risk too
you have to rely on them going to work
to pay for your profits that's a risk on
their behalf what if they don't get paid
and if you do and if it does fail that's
just a bad investment right right but
that's what happens when you just invest
in property which is an
unsustainable um I'd say business one
but it's not but the fundamental thing
at the end of the day is I don't think
being a land isn't a business is it it's
just having Capital to have enough money
to buy more housing to then profit off
of it I wouldn't say that's a service or
producing the product well firstly we're
not talking about being a landlord here
I think being a landord is a business
but we're talking here about being a
property developer yeah and there's do
separate things I would say though like
being a pure landord they do go they do
kind of coist together because once
you've built something you might then
rent it out or you might sell it or if
you sell it you might sell it to a
landlord who then rents it out um but if
you had five million quid that you'd
worked hard on and saved up from from
scratch would you risk it at building 48
I would never I would never be a
landlord I I would if I had 5 million
quid I would probably build a business
something enjoy but I'd never be a
landlord because I I don't want to
engage in um a practice that leeches
from society that doesn't add any social
utility and it makes it harder for
people it makes it it contributes to the
housing crisis it really does and then I
don't like the idea that I'm extracting
profit from renters who were struggling
to get on the housing lad so no I
personally wouldn't do it I think that's
a a bad business practice I don't I
don't think is particularly moral um but
I want to make distinction between
landlords and property managers cuz I
I've got no quarms of property managers
they're they're doing actual work
they're doing they're providing a a
value to society so I got no issues with
that that's fine just purely being a
landlord which is not really doing any
work at allbody stop being a landlord if
all the landlords just said you know
what from now on we've listened
to yes sell up your housing make them
cheaper no no no we're gonna just Bard
up our houses and we're not going to
rent them out and we're just not going
to be landlords what would happen is is
we'd have absolute devastation in across
the country yeah if you're not going to
sell them I mean sell them off you're
not going to sit on an asset you don't
need right which is to be fair which is
fair that is actually happening though
because when youve got like the Russian
oligarchs coming over here buying up
investment properties not even to to
rent out but to wait and then sell it
off so that's actually happening under
this system as well but if everyone did
that though or even if everyone said
sell it off even if everyone said we're
just going to sell all our properties
people can't afford to buy the
properties they people want to rent they
want to be tenants I I disagree they do
not want to rent there are some people
who do but there are millions of people
who desperately want to buy a house but
they can't afford it and having a
middleman inside having a a landlord in
the middle of it is pushing up prices so
I'd say if there's less landlords and
the uh there's a huge infl um influx of
housing on the market the prices will
come down that make that would mean
it'll be easier to get a house and again
I've also said that we should have state
renting so we shouldn't have a middleman
so I don't think I don't see how
landlords provide that uh value but
again I do agree if it was just an
overnight thing there would be trouble
this would have to be a transitional
process every time I get paid in my how
I see is it's a certificate of thanks so
when someone gives me money whether that
be a tenant whether that be a developer
because I've sold off some flats that
I've built whether that be a student
that's paid for some education whether
that be whoever pays me money the way I
see it is they're saying thank you let's
exchange I want your product I want your
service so the Richer I get the more
fulfilled I am and of course I then have
a sense of responsibility to be a good
person with that money to help people to
make the world a better place so that's
My Philosophy that that that's the way I
see it I don't know how how you see
money or how you I know you don't like
landlords I don't know what the
alternative is I mean you say about the
state everywhere that I've looked at
from my research that this the
government have owned all the properties
and have been the ultimate landlords it
it's it's always ended terribly because
capitalism makes people want to have a
competitive Advantage good product to be
able to sell you get better services and
better products when when it's a free
market um so that's my stance you know
okay I mean there's a few things that
I'll touch on touch upon um the first
one is your view is that okay it's a
product I'm giving you know it's a
thanks that is your the way you feel
fine that's your personal opinion on it
but I'm I'm trying to come at it up from
a systemic thing right I'm again I'm not
trying to you say I hate lards I don't
hate lards um I don't particularly like
lanord who view people as lower than
them not saying that's you although you
some of your tweets have been a bit
Dodge but there are some people out
there who are just genuinely horrible
and there are some landlords out there
who are who are nice I know people have
friends who are landlords um so this is
not about like a morality argument the
argument is and to to just kind of
briefly round it up is that I feel like
that when it comes to private
landlordism it actually makes the system
unsustainable housing is is a huge
problem and if you say well I make if I
make loads of money off a property that
makes me sleep at night CU that means I
can use that money to reinvest in
housing that is the argument that many
people have made and I guess it makes
logical sense but I I think there's a
lot of things that are missing out of
that one is if you again your your buy
low rent high for example that would
inflate rent prices because there are
other people think you know what I can
do the same I can increase my rent and
that that's just a race to the bottom
for other landlords too you may not be
thinking I you might be think you're
doing a good service there'll be other
people out there who like yes I can
exploit that so I think that's one issue
um in terms of capitalism this is where
I take issue um about capitalism from a
landlord because being a landlord is
very anti- capitalist and not in the
good sense you know I'm a socialist I
I'm I am anti- capitalist but lism isn't
capitalism in fact um I'm sure you're
aware of Adam Smith The Economist who
wrote loads of books including the
wealth and Nations he was a big
proponent of capitalism he hated
landlords and also KL marks again he was
on the other political side of the
spectrum they both had the same analysis
of landlords and that was um Adam Smith
envisions a low profit High competition
system but landlords don't create that
essentially landlords create a
monopolization and the the the Richer
you become the the more successful you
are the more um monopolization happens
and also under capitalism the point of
exchange is to a business produces a
product reduces a social utility and a
customer buys it and and that seems
quite fair and early liberal economists
um is theory on capitalism makes it
sound pretty great even as a leftist I
mean if if capitalism was what it was
promised to be I'd probably be a
capitalist but that's not what's
happening and landlords aren't producing
a social utility that is being being
exchange rather um value is being
extracted out of thin air through
customers paying more for getting less
value that's the two biggest things I
wanted to say say on that but it but
it's not a capitalist thing I mean we
used to live under feudalism we used to
have peasants in in uh the merchant
class and landlords and that what we had
before and before then it was the
inherited land now it's um you know you
might say you work hard for it but again
I think the economy when you look at the
the facts and how the economy set up
majority people don't go through social
Mobility so it's it's just another way
of breeding an elite uh which is
landlords um it's a landord it's a class
that shouldn't really exist and I don't
think it's helpful for capitalism
because capitalism would be better if
there was competition I don't see how
buying up housing stock renting it for a
profit sometimes extortionate rents
which again you you might CLA that's not
the case but other people do that
doesn't seem very that doesn't seem like
a healthy competition under under a
capitalist system so do you think that
all landlords are scum no I I I've I've
said multiple times that I don't try to
make the moral argument that all lands
are bad that's not the case I think
there are some as I said I've got
friends who are landlords there are some
people who are pretty decent are
landlords the system why do you think
that I am scum based on my business
practices I don't think you're scum
based on your being a Lord um and I
think that the the things you've done on
social media are they're not they're not
great and I think the the publicity
stunt you said it was a publicity stunt
right that is not helpful during the
cost of living crisis during what's
happening what's going on and also but
but I will say though that just as you
say that look I I provide content and
stuff I put a thumbnail that said scum
landlord but I'm not going to completely
judge you so I'm not I'm not looking at
you thinking you're an absolute scum
it's because was and we we've had a chat
but when I'm seeing a video of that I'm
thinking what a scum llord bit a bit of
offthe cuff comment but again this I
don't want to bring it back to the
morality argument because that's not
helpful it's it's the systemic issue at
play here I don't really agree no I
don't I don't think so because I I don't
know what the other alternative is I
agree that there's a lot of bad
landlords and that's and that's wrong
but I also think there's a lot of
legislation there's an awful lot of
legislation to stop landlords kicking
out tenants without giving a lot notied
because it is a human right to have a
home there's a lot of legislation on
that there's also a lot of legislation
and maybe in some areas it needs to be
improved but there's a lot there is a
lot of legislation around living
standards and minimum size and things
like that um but I just don't know what
the alternative is I think that the idea
of the well I have provided some
Alternatives well well well well the
thing is the
council are the worst landlords they are
terrible I mean the worst properties
that people live in are Council
properties the horror stories that I
hear from my tenants that say look at
this and they show you pictures of
counsel so the fact that you're saying
we shouldn't have landlords we should
just let the council be the ultimate
landlord that's not the AR that's not
the argument so I provided a couple of
Alternatives but to to talk about the
cancel for a second one I think you're
referring to I think austerity we've had
13 years of austerity under Tory
government um we used to have better
quality housing but I think you're
looking at correlation and causation and
a lot of people think this when the
government does something it's
automatically bad I don't think that's
particularly the case it's it's how
something's funded right you can you can
have personal anecdotes about bad cancer
housing but again there's so many
personal anecdotes about private
landlords there are people who have died
due to mold for example because some
landlords have um neglected it and you
would argue they're a bad landlord fine
but that's technically allowed to happen
under the system so I think it's really
easy to look at councel hous and like oh
they're really bad that's why we need
private land think C what do you think
you said that you don't think there's
really a place for landlords they're not
adding no not at all no private
landlordism I mean I'm not saying that
everyone has to own their own home
because I would like to get to a a
society
where buying in renting is purely down
to choice and I dispute the fact that
you think people choose to rent I don't
think that's the case but I would like
to get to a point where that is the case
because people want there are legitimate
reasons to rent maybe they're not help
out Comm help me out then yeah educate
what would be a better system as if I am
a child explain to
me okay so I've already identified uh
before uh probably two two different
ways one is is I do think that you can
rent off the state but it obviously
depends on what kind of government you
have and if you have a Tory austerity
ridden government that that is
potentially a problem right can but you
can have renting off the state another
one which I said before which is what we
go back to which is building societies
well we actually have building societies
where local
communities um would get Capital either
partly through funding from a building
society and partly from local
communities that's another way of doing
it and a third option which is pretty
good I think is is um housing
cooperatives where literally local
communities chipping together without
any sort of big overarching uh company
or whatever or state there's regulations
of course and local communities do that
and then that is housing which is more
more efficient I'd say because it's
targeting places where people need it
and it's also taken out the profit
motive and it's taking out the
exploitation inheriting the system that
is landlordism sure so of those three
much Superior methods than the current
one that we have which is to have a free
market and have private landlords which
you think is bad of those three methods
well I don't think it's a free market
though I do dispute that okay I
think okay we've got 195 countries right
now in the world which country is doing
what you think would be a better
solution ution is it successful CU I'll
go and I'll check it out yeah I would
say I mean no one's doing it on a Mass
state scale but some of the Nordic
countries have got some country one
country where this works across the
board I'll give you I'll give you I'll
give you I'll give you Denmark n Norway
and Sweden right again visit them
beautiful countries they don't have a
they're not quite as radical but they're
going they're making the the right step
I think which is having a bit more State
provision in it they're not again like I
said I'm not even though I don't think
landlords should exist I my policy isn't
just to ban them outright overnight cuz
that wouldn't work the better thing to
do would to have exactly a a transition
hold on hold on hold on a second a trans
let me finish a transition period where
ultimately being a landlord is no longer
worth it and you slowly sort of you know
slowly wean them off it but you're
asking me what country I'm telling you
the policies there's there isn't one
country that has implemented the
Socialist Utopia I want there that
doesn't exist I'm just talking about
specific policies which are good and can
be helpful and one of the policies I'm
talking about is what we used to do
which is um uh building societies that's
something that used to used to work so
again it's I feel like your dichotomy is
over landlords or no landlords and
without landlords you have no housing I
agree that if we were to get rid of
landlords overnight there is going to be
a huge supply issue but that doesn't
mean the system is working and the
system is efficient I don't think it is
I think we can something better which is
a slow transition to much more um
democratic
um and much more localized policy but
you see listen this is the thing you see
you seem like a nice person seem like an
intelligent person does it not does it
not strike you that there's not one
country in the world where it what
you're saying
Works what again though but I feel
that's like the no true Scotsman fallacy
because you could be like well tell me
where capitalism works oh it works in
this country but there's actually a lot
a lot of issues with capitalism right
guess what China is a capitalist country
why what's wrong with with China I I
don't want to live in China due to their
authoritarian States so it's obviously
implemented wrong so I think it's it is
I think it's like a debate ending thing
to say like what country works and I
don't think that's an intelligent
question to ask re hashing out policy is
is more important but to get like a
gotcha answer where has it worked where
doesn't it work I'm sure but I'm saying
it doesn't work here I mean you're very
very wealthy from what you got so from
your point of view it works just as well
but I don't think you can say that the
housing system we have and you would
even agree there's a lot of flaws to our
system that it works here so I think if
you're going to ask me which country
works and which country doesn't it's
it's a bit more Nuance on that because
obviously I would rather live in the UK
than somewhere like China even though
they're a state capitalist Society but
there still thing there's still things
that need to be improved in this country
too sure I mean there's no perfect
system and every every system that you
know there's no wherever you've got
people involved and hum involved um
there's always going to be problems and
complications um but yeah I I just I
just can't it does what you're saying
about abolishing landlords to me it
doesn't make any sense but I respect not
abolishing but you know one day one day
ab you know what I think it's I respect
the fact that you know you you you've
had this convo with me and uh and I'm
I'm I'm open-minded and if I come across
and find a better solution a better
system then maybe I'll give away all my
money and and and and follow that that
better system but for now being a
landlord being a developer and being
rich I think works perfectly well and
think that I also help a lot more people
um homeless people employ employing
people that than most people do and I
think that that should be celebrated and
applauded Samuel um I just want to say
thank you so much for coming on uh you
reached out to me um and you did a video
about me I did do a video about you but
you did comment and you reached out me
to debate I'll just say this very
quickly you did a video about me and
said scum landlord a picture of me with
the word scum on it and I said to you um
if you think I'm a scum landlord let's
have a debate about it and you're one of
the very few people that that that that
have come on and debated so I respect
that and it's been fun and no and again
I want to give you your props that you
have you've debated me really
interesting discussion again I don't
think happens a lot but I will say thank
you for your time and I really
appreciate it Curtis thank you my friend
speak you soon thank you